herzlich willkommen beim ein video hatte
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut
erstmals so wie das jetzt in drei tagen
kein video kam habe es leider nicht
geschafft aber das gute ist ja heute
gibt es wieder eins guck mal wir haben
ja ein neues feature im wohnzimmer der
fernseher der leuchtet jetzt rot von
hinten hatte einmal kurz licht aus so
leute nichts jetzt mal schnell bei der
schufa auch wenn die kamera ein bisschen
dreckig ist steht heute was wirklich
sehr sehr cooles an oder wir werden
natürlich erst mal sehen ob das pulver
ich habe letztens irgendwann durch
zufall mal gesehen dass es bei
mcdonald's so viele produkte gibt also
ich hab die ganze karte gesehen und so
so viel davon kenne ich gar nicht kannte
ich gar nicht keinen plan wie schmecken
mal so als ganzes beispiel glitter
kartoffeln what the [ __ ] oder kakao
kirsch tasche was ist es deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht wenn das nicht passiert
hast machst du einfach soll ein test und
bestellt zwar das ganze szenario will
diese macdonald auf mein vertrauen and
buy belassen es besser mit dem
englischen von jetzt los und kaufen mal
das eine oder andere produkt wer zuerst
beim autos hat gewonnen
ja und jetzt macht
übrigens mal kurz sagen muss schaut euch
mal die felgen an die sind ja noch
silber damit passiert damit noch was
ganz besonderes nicht mit den felgen
gerne reduzieren
deswegen seit auf jeden fall aufs
nächste auto video gespannt um der
gefahr leute am allerschlimmsten erwarte
ich noch kurz die lichter in köln sind
am allerschlimmsten die fahrradfahrer
weil die fand wie wollen die denken die
sind die einzigen ach so legal zurück
zum thema auf jeden fall ein ich habe
mich gerade so eine kleine sachen laufen
und zwar im ich kann ich auch mal fragen
ob wir darauf war bock habt aber ich
denke schon und zwar bezüglich meiner
ganzen macdonald videos darf ich immer
toll demnächst im wald einen tag bei
mcdonald probe arbeiten und wir das
ganze mal so anschauen
ihr könnt ja auf jeden fall jetzt mal
fetten daumen nach oben geben wenn ihr
darauf gehabt also ich schon ich bin
gespannt
ja genau also lässt man nach oben da und
wir sind
die wackel total
danke dass du dich dafür bereit erklärt
meine kamera
ich gucke mir vorsichtshalber erst mal
alex ist sehr sehr sehr großes vorbild
für euch weil er hält an wo vorher auf
sein handy also ich bin ja leicht ich
hatte mir eigentlich eben schon sachen
rausgesucht screenshot das ist einfach
alles ich hätte gerne einmal die gitter
kartoffeln oder bleibt gibt's hier die
charakteristische ja dann nehme ich denn
da wild schießen lief einzeln ein
milchshake weinreich
und lemon cas oder das heißt ach so und
dann dazu kommt noch dass demmin kis
getränkt ja das war es eigentlich okay
danke schön an gewalt
ich hab ich schon auch noch so was ist
das für einer die fertigstellung meines
lebens mit kamera weg was ein klasse
über leute dann herzlich willkommen
zurück in unseren breiten so mein ziel
ist es jetzt diesen tisch hier so stehen
zu lassen und hier einfach den rest
aufzunehmen ich mich ganz ok aber
nochmal die kennedys ein bisschen schief
oder das ist doch jetzt also leute
willkommen
das ist das alter wenn ich das schon
sehen
es können doch so einem chip sein der
läuft uns war hier einmal einen
milchshake wartete das ist natürlich so
eine sache
ich glaube milchshakes werden ab und zu
schon bestellt nur ich hab doch nie
einmal probiert und kann das überhaupt
nicht sagen vor allem von den nicht
weder bei den schwingen und die haben
etwas ganz neues das ist das leveln wie
ist das nochmal namen cash the man kist
getränk das gibt es auch in cherry aber
das habe ich irgendwie vergessen zu
kommen dass ich eigentlich noch kommen
könnte dazu kommt noch ein special
burger ts ach so das ist vegetarier weiß
wirklich glaube ich nur was glaube ich
wirklich keiner stellt ist griff ließ
dass das sind die richtigen moment
absolut ich dachte das heißt glitter
kartoffeln reis im gitter kartoffeln
keine ahnung sonstige den mann zusammen
mit seiner frau dann habe ich jetzt noch
bestellt das hier ist ebenso eine kakao
cherry cacau cherry tasche kann kaum
kirsche das ist die couch tasche und
noch ein bürger von dem ich auch vorher
noch nie gehört habe das ist der agence
de das ist der dabei schießen bacon ja
also das video echt gut aus so leute
also probieren wir mal die glitzer
das sind twitter dafür jetzt für mich
wir haben wir mit der solisten wissen
[Musik]
kommt also bläser kartoffel ist auf
jeden fall gemacht für kurze hose
die saucen
also eigentlich ein ziemlich großer
vanille alter der ist voll geil
das war selten sondern der kunde schnell
gefunden also wird sagen dass man es mit
dem wir auf jeden fall zum schluss jetzt
kommt noch kurz für diese bürger
bisschen eine tomate und nicht an
ich hasse tomaten haben einmal das ist
der zweite vegetarische burger meines
lebens es jetzt echt nicht so mein fall
dann fange ich jetzt gar nicht gut da
ich liebe der sollte mal zeigen wie ein
richtiger burger aussieht hat mir auch
leute gebt euch mal diesen bürger hier
was alltäglich erste mega für alte leute
jetzt hier den dammer bergen da will
da will irgendwas damit schießt oder so
ist wenn ich mal gespannt was am mund
also man tut damit jetzt auch als
trainer sieht ja ich mich ob ich okay
also darf ich auf jeden fall zum besten
burger man den gästen so hat jetzt haben
wir noch zwei sachen die glaube ich
wirklich was niemand kennt also ich kann
ich das nicht mal und ich bin relativ
oft da hätte ich das jetzt haben soll
so auch bin ich auch nicht da also wir
haben ja zu lemon beer ist dass man als
höre ich schon wieder vergessen ländern
kist und cherry kakao oder so ich
probier erst mal kurz das hier was genau
soll das jetzt sei das schlägt auf jeden
fall ziemlich sauber das schmeckt echt
sommer nämlich die rutschen
[Musik]
also dachte ich mir besser noch dieses
charity von holen und jetzt kommen wir
zu dem was mich am meisten interessiert
jetzt kann man vielleicht wird der
körper ein bisschen näher
was ist das sich auf jeden fall nicht so
lecker aus du musst es schon aufstehen
oder sehen sie man sieht das gut aus
ja es geht nicht immer erkennen das geht
doch darum dass es wieder gut aussieht
guckt euch mal dass thailand wie sieht
das aus kienbaum spärlichen ich glaube
das ist von der kamera filmen das
schlechteste video auf meine mannschaft
die hälfte vom wild vollständig decke
oder wand wenn ich jetzt ganz drauf zu
packen
die leute wir beispiel in die cantautori
kirschbaum sturm dann schmeckt wollen
nach weihnachten und schritte mega
ehrlich heute darf ich sagen ich gerade
bestelle ich dass man heute guckt euch
das mal geil ja also leute auch wenn ihr
mich nicht ich bin mir nicht sicher
lasst noch nach oben dafür einen tag
macdonald und probiert mal dass hier
vielleicht auch meine den echt coole
sachen dabei das einzige was mich jetzt
zwar umgehauen hat davon ist dass hier
egal sektion film ihr engster berater
wir sehen uns morgen wieder machen
gibt's gleich video haut rein 21 geräumt